hi in this video we're going to talk
about network data
and how it works in android and then
i'll prepare you for a tutorial that's
to follow
[Music]
so there are three things that we're
going to examine in this video we're
going to talk about what a rest api
is then we're going to talk about how to
program what's called
asynchronous code and then finally we'll
talk about the volley library
so rest api is a term that you'll see in
programming languages
everywhere it's really about clients and
servers
the api stands for something called an
application
program interface and really in plain
english it means that there's a server
somewhere
that's providing data to the client so
that way you have either
phones computers or watches or something
out there that is relying on a service
on the internet
in the following videos we're going to
create a tutorial in android using a
rest api
from the service called metaweather.com
and so we're going to have a service
that looks like this where it provides
you with
a weekly forecast and it will be up to
us to design the user interface
so that that data comes out and looks
good
so a rest api is a service that lets you
look at specific urls such as the
address that you see listed here and
instead of responding with an html page
a web page
you get a back a a pure data form so it
looks something like this here where it
says london city
and an id number so rest apis and
microservices are two terms that often
appear together
so sometimes a development team will
break up an application into pieces
into micro pieces you might say and they
use apis to talk between those pieces
so a server can usually be split up into
tasks
so this is a traditional model you might
see so we have at the bottom we have a
database we have a data interface we
have a business logic and then the user
interface
a multi-tiered approach well in
microservices you might say well
that one data interface is actually
could be split up into multiple pieces
and we'll call them microservices
microservices can talk directly to the
user interface or they might provide
data to other microservices so that way
you can have
a modular approach to building your
program the link between
those is the api so the text messages
that are traded between
clients and servers are usually done in
two different languages
one is json and the other is xml there
are others but those are the two most
common
so this is what json data looks like you
can see that this is a weather report
and you can also see that it is very
easily understood when you look at it
tells you what the id number is the type
of
weather that's for the day you can see
the minimum temperatures the maximums
it's pretty much readable as a human
would be able to
see it but you can also see that there
are specific quotations and colons
and so it's a very data delimited piece
of text
now the same data could have been
created in an
xml format and so the xml format looks a
little bit like
you just expect a web page it's a
hypertext it's got these brackets and an
open and enclosed tag and so they're not
exactly
doing the exact same process xml has a
little bit more
functions to it and it's not as popular
either so most people are working on the
left side here
with json data in their apis so json
stands for
javascript object notation and it can be
configured to send
messages in not just json formats apis
can be in others
but usually json is the type of data
that you would expect to see
it's really common and despite its name
json is not limited to javascript
so json can be used in many different
programming languages
so if rest is associated with json then
the terminology soap
is usually associated with xml so soap
stands for simple object access protocol
it it's very similar to rest but you can
only see xml data when it comes to soap
so you could see json being used with
rest
and xml being used with soap
but they're both pretty much producing
the same
results here they're both trying to
communicate text messages to a client
so let's talk a minute about the client
and the server
so the client's job is usually the one
that says i will initiate the request i
will ask for some data
and the results will be sent back into
the
the format that the client can
understand so we're going to follow this
video with a tutorial that will show you
how to use the client for
android so your client could be a phone
it could be a desktop it could be a
watch it could be another server
but the client and server is just kind
of a generic way to think about it
so that we will use a phone here in our
example but in other cases we could just
as easily have
programmed this as a web page so what
does an api look like
so the rest service usually have some
kind of an
end point that provides access to the
client
so in this example we have a url from
the website
metaweather.com api location and then a
location number
and then what follows from that is the
weather report for that specific
id number which happens to be the city
of london and so in a
traditional web page you would at the
green part of the stack of items you
would have said this is the web page
in a rest service we would say the url
endpoint is not a web page
it's just pure text and then the client
is responsible to format that text
into the proper user interface so how
much work does it take to create a back
end
does it have to be written in android is
have to be written in java what's the
language
well the truth is it doesn't matter what
the language is
and server applications can be written
in php c-sharp they could be written in
java
node they could be written in ruby
python
pretty much any language that can create
text files
and call and communicate with a network
is going to be eligible to make rest
services
so the middle part here in the business
logic can be any language that you
choose it's pretty much irrelevant
and so your team sometimes are split up
as a back-end developer and a front-end
developer
and that's thanks to the ability to
create these apis that can
bridge the gap between the front and the
back end
now since there is such a nice standard
with json you can format the data to be
output no matter what language that
you're working with
and so we have no idea what
metaweather.com used as their backend
whether it was java c-sharp or something
else
now think about the amount of effort so
the ui the user interface in the front
end
approximately takes about half of the
amount of effort that it would take
in the back end of course that
determines that's determined by the
complexity of your application sometimes
the back end is really the secret sauce
of an app and that's what would take the
majority of the time
so if you're interested in learning how
to create the back end i have other
tutorials classes on php
classes on java classes on c sharp
and all of those using their frameworks
and their full stack will
allow you to see how to create the
database
and then the urls that are providing
these services to you
but for the sake that's going to follow
here we're going to create an
android application that is going to use
a pre-existing
free open source api so we will only do
half the work really
for this weather app another feature
that you're going to see
in this application tutorial is that
there is the idea
of asynchronous code now in most
examples of coding you're probably used
to seeing
synchronous code that means one line
follows the other you can trace through
exactly the order of statements in a
program
however with callbacks or asynchronous
code
we have an external process going on and
that's why
in network programming here the idea of
asynchronous
or callbacks is going to be super
important so let's take an example here
so i have some code in this gray box and
its function
says get me some data and it says i want
to go to a website
a url an api let's say
and i want to get some user data so it
looks like we're looking for user number
99 now that's going to take some time
because of the network
traffic and it's kind of could be on the
other side of the world it might take
the couple of seconds for that response
to happen
and so we're not going to sit around and
wait for it we're going to
jump right into the next item in the in
the program
so we're going to continue running
that's the synchronous mode
and we're going to just forget about our
network request and let him catch up
later
now that catch-up later process is
called the callback
and so when the process is done there
will be an alert sent to your
application that says hey
data's arrived and what do you want to
do with it so the callback function will
have a parameter
like a list or some kind of a string or
something
and that will say hey i got the data
back from the server
and now in this green or in the sorry in
this red processing
box here you can go ahead and process
process that data it means you can save
it to the database or display it to the
user
or whatever your choice is but the
callback is going to
occur at some later time and we're not
sure if it's going to be a millisecond
later or
a minute later but it will be a delay so
let's take a look at actually some of
the code that we're going to develop
here so
we are going to define a callback
function and it will run
after a set of data has successfully
been retrieved from an online
service and so here's what it's going to
look like we're going to have a button
click
for get weather by name and
we are going to call this a service
called the weather service
and it's going to get the forecast so
it's some function
and it's an asynchronous function so
following that we're going to have two
options
so when this is done we are going to
have a
on error that's a possibility that
nothing came back
or it was badly formatted or we're going
to have a response
and you can see in the response that i
am updating an arrayadapter so i'm
showing a list
on my ui so this is the actual java code
that we're going to be coding
in a tutorial in the next video so this
asynchronous process is going to help us
with what's called
non-blocking code so non-blocking code
is to allow other tasks in an
application to continue running
and not block up the user interface
so you can see in the example in this
timeline here that we
in the first example would be a
synchronous execution
so we stop all processing and wait for
our response
however in the second example below you
can see that we are going to
start the external process the network
request
but then we're going to go on and do
other things we're going to keep
processing
the threads you might say and uh we're
gonna have
things going in parallel and so it'll
prevent the application from freezing up
so the first process will continue
executing and then the
other code will work in the background
in android and in all applications the
user
interface thread is important not to
block
so we have a task list here you can see
i've got four applications running
on my application we don't want them to
stop
there is a literal loop or a looper they
call it an infinite loop a while loop
that continually checks on each task and
gives each task a little bit of
processing power
so it's the scheduler in the operating
system now
if we were to stop one of those tasks
and it had to sit
and wait for a response then your
whole phone will freeze and it'll appear
like your application is dead
you might get an application alert that
says the process isn't responding what
do you want to do close the app
you might want to and if the user does
that then you'll probably never come
back to your app they'll call it a buggy
app
and you don't want that to happen so in
instead what we're going to do
is we're going to use this interface
thread
which is responsible to keep the user
interface running
we're not going to mess that up instead
we're going to offload this to a
background task
and we'll let that handle the retrieval
of network information
and that way the looper can continue to
go on and the user can continue to
choose menus and buttons
and just wait for the weather to get
updated in the uh in the second app
now to do all this network requests and
all this looping and background
processing
there are libraries that are built to
help handle these kind of things
so android has several libraries
available to us
there's one called volley and another
one called retrofit
so volley is the official documented
library that you would find on the
android tutorials and that's the one
we're going to use it's been around for
a long time
however there's another one called
retrofit and it's actually probably
more feature-fold it might be a little
bit easier to use
and it's actually shown up recently in
the process called the
jetpack so jetpack is a as a collection
of libraries that are considered
best practices by google and so even
though we're not going to use
retrofit it might be a better choice for
future programming
but they they work very similarly so the
concepts will be the same
in either library so here's what's ahead
of us we're going to create a weather
application using an
api and an android so we're going to
install the volley library
we're going to parse a json data feed
and then we're going to use
asynchronous methods using callbacks to
update our user interface
and so all of that stuff is just ahead
of us so let's take a look
at how to build a weather app using
android
hey welcome to a new series of videos
we're going to do for android
development
as you can see i have an app on the
screen and i'm going to show you what it
does
so if i type in the word of a city like
phoenix and choose use city name as my
button
i should see a list of temperatures
weather reports and so that's what we're
going to make in this next few videos
[Music]
so this weather app is going to
demonstrate how to use
rest api services and so you can see
that i've got the current temperature
and the current forecast for my city you
can see the phoenix weather is pretty
boring it's clear clear
clear clear clear and some showers
perhaps
it gets pretty hot here so we're up to
that's celsius that's 43 degrees
so the type of data that i'm going to
get looks like here so for instance if i
do a
search for the query of the city of
london i'm going to get back
a json report that looks like this it's
going to have an array
and an object and then you can see i
have london
and then this important number here
which is the id number for this
city so i'm going to copy that number
and we're going to use it in another
api endpoint so let's scroll down here
and see what what this would do
so for instance here i'm going to choose
this example for london
and you can see the number 44418 is for
london
and the weather report then shows up as
a series of
text really it's json and then some
other things that tell us about where we
got the information from
and what we're going to do is turn this
into an application that runs on
android and so you can make your own
weather report app
so let's see what some of the other
things that i've programmed are so if i
type in the name
phoenix again and choose get city id
you're going to see a pop-up that says
the id number down here
so let's go back and try what they gave
us as an example here london
so london england i assume and we'll
choose get city id
and you can see 44418 is the number
so now i'm going to choose 44418 as my
entry
and the second button says use the city
id and now you can see that i'm going to
get a report
for the london weather so that looks
like it's probably correct light clouds
heavy clouds showers
that's not phoenix and then finally the
last part where it says city name
if i change this to london it's going to
use
this api twice it's going to first of
all look up the
id number and then it will re-submit the
id number in and give us the weather
report so we're going to
go from simple to more complex you're
going to see some things in this
tutorial that will teach you about rest
services
how to consume apis and how to do
some callbacks because this is like an
asynchronous function
so this is a little bit more advanced
programming when we've got
online services involved so i'm going to
take you through step by step on how to
build this application we'll start with
showing how to create the layout and
then we'll install the
volley library which is used for getting
online
data like we have here and then we're
going to program each of these buttons
so the first one is simple the second
one one's a little more complex
and then the third one is a double call
to the service so
go simple to more complex and by the
time you're done
you'll understand how to use rest api
services
in your android application hi in this
video we're going to go through the
process of creating the layout for the
application you can see here
it's a rest api service that will turn
into a weather app
so the first steps that we're going to
do is create a new project
we're going to create three buttons a
data entry line and then a list
and so that's just a hit so i'm going to
start a new project so you can see
everything straight from the very
beginning
so let's go to android studio i'm going
to choose an
empty activity project and let's give it
a name
so i'm going to name mine as weather api
app
you can see the package name is the name
of where i work which is grand canyon
university my name and then weather app
so this has to be a unique string
this is usually the format that people
work with the location
you can save to any point on your hard
drive likely in your documents folder
make sure that you choose java kotlin is
the more
up-to-date language but java still is by
far the more popular
and i'm not quite sure what the minimum
sdk is for java
so i'm choosing 21 which is pretty much
covering everybody out there so 94
and then i'm ready to click finish
all right you can see that the little
time has passed and the project is up
and running
so just to refresh your memory we've got
ourselves two files that are important
when you start a new project there's the
activity main i'll double click
and you can see that's the layout and
then the main activity java file
is where we do the coding so in this
video we're going to
modify the layout and we're going to
create something that will look like
the final product so the first thing i
need to do is just delete the text
that's there so i will select hello
world and press delete
now i'm going to put in three buttons
across the top
all right so now the tricky part of
getting these three buttons spaced out
is to manage their constraints properly
so for the first button we're going to
put the constraint to the top of the
screen
and to the left for the second button
we're going to have the top of the
constraint match the top of the first
button
and then we're going to do the same
thing for the third
so now i've got i'm trying to adjust
these so i'm
changing the margins to zero so there's
no extra padding
but i'm having trouble linking them left
and right so they're all lined up at the
top
but i think i need to go into the text
area so instead of looking at the
graphical view
i'm going to switch to the code view so
this brings up the xml
and i can manually put in the things
that i need to do here so
let's see button one is which guy the
first one right here this is button
and let's make sure we got the
constraints right so the start of
the button is to the start of the parent
now the end of the button goes to button
two that's correct now let's go to
button
two and let's see so his doesn't have a
beginning
constraint so i'm going to manually add
that so i'm going to type in the word
start of and you can see that it
automatically provides me with a
type ahead so i want to do the first
choice that can the start of this button
is going to match the end of the
previous button so i'll select the first
one
and now it says which button do you want
to select so this first one
all right so now the end of the button
is going to be constrained to the start
of the pre of the
the third button that's correct and the
top
should match the top of the first button
okay so i believe button two is in the
right spot let's check the graphics
there you can see the button one and
button two are evenly spaced
and this uh kind of wavy line says this
is there's a two-way constraint going on
now we need to add the constraints for
the third button to spread him out so
let's go back to code
and i'm going to do the same so let's
see let's check the constraints
so the end of this button goes to the
end of the parent which is the
right margin that's correct the top of
the sky matches the top of button two
so yes they're horizontally uh they're
going to be the same vertical distance
down
now i want to change the constraint to
be the start of this
is going to be to the end of
the previous buttons so i'm looking for
start
to end of and now it says the end of who
that would be the end of button two
which is the center button
all right so now we have a end
start and top that looks
good to me let's check the view in
graphics now
and they are now all evenly spaced so
that's kind of a tricky thing how to get
these spaced across
evenly all right so now i want to rename
these
instead of button button two and button
three i'm going to give them names that
match the purpose
for which i'm going to program them so
i'm going to switch to this middle
button which is called split
and you can see the xml code and the
layout here on the right
so i want to modify this first button
here
and his name is currently button
so i want to change his id to btn
underscore and then his purpose which is
get city id
and you can see that all of the
constraints just fell apart
that's because down here in the second
button
you can see it's still thinking that
button is the
guy he's supposed to be attached to so
that doesn't work obviously so i'm going
to copy
and paste this id number over top of
those
and now the constraints are back to
normal good okay so now let's change the
id number
for button two so he is going to be btn
and his job is to get the weather
by city id so when you click this we're
going to have
the ability to translate an id number to
a city uh
weather report so that's why we get get
weather by city
id and you can see i'm going to copy
this
and the reference down here needs to
change so paste over top of that
and paste over top the second one and
they're back good
all right so what happens this one needs
to be pasted
so i'm replacing the id numbers let's
see the third one is button three
and so here is going to be btn and we're
going to say get weather
by city name so you can see the
difference this one was city id
we're going to provide the name of the
city here to get the weather report
all right so let's copy him and replace
this reference here to button three
and i believe that is now balancing out
correctly so
that was a little tricky but we got all
of our buttons in a row
and we changed their id numbers all
right so now we've got to give the
button text something better than what
we have here so
the text is there anything in here about
the text
there is not a property listed in the
xml for text so let's go back to the
graphical view
and i'm going to select the first and
let's go
check the properties so here is a text
property it says button
so we're going to say get city id
is his name all right so that changed
the text property
this one here is going to be get
weather by id number
and then the last one is going to be the
same it's get weather by
name
and let's see they are not quite fitting
so
let's change this and i'll just say
get gets out of the way and we'll say
whether by id and the other one will be
weather by name
and there's just barely enough space so
that probably will work
now that's the buttons let's go to the
next part which is
a text edit so plain text is what i'm
looking for
and i'm going to drag him in and you can
see why i called it edit text because
that's the default name or the id
let's put the constraints in so i want
this to be attached to the left margin
and the other end to the right margin
and now i want the width to be the full
width so let's change the width to 0dp
which is also known as match constraints
so it spreads out to the full width now
the top of this thing let's
match it to the bottom of the first
button
so let's see we want the top to the get
city by id bottom and then it says i'm
automatically going to leave you an 88
pixels margin let's just change that to
8 so it's pretty close
that looks pretty good now let's give
this a name so instead of edit text
we're going to say
et underscore data input so it's a
generic data input we're going to use it
to
capture names and numbers so i'm just
going to call it
et data input now let's see down in the
bottom we're going to see a text area so
it says name i'm going to delete that
and for hint i'm going to say city name
is a good hint
and now we've got city name listed all
right so the last one
is a is a list so i need to go to
the common area and you can see that
recyclerview
is the common most recommended thing
if you want to use a list view if you
want to display
a list of any items and scroll through
it recyclerview is the recommended way
now you can do that if you like however
there's a lot of extra code and steps
that are involved compared to
a legacy option so even though this is
legacy
i'm choosing list view because it's so
simple
now the advantages of list view are its
simplicity
but the disadvantage is if you start
adding
hundreds of items to a list it will run
very slowly and consume all kinds of
resources on your app
well i know that on my list i'm only
going to have five items
and it's so simple to program i'm going
with list view
all right so let's do the constraints
here so the top of this has to match to
the bottom of the
data input and let's leave a little
space here let's go 8 pixels
let's go with the left side to match the
left here
and the right side equally drag to the
right
alright so you can see the constraints
are here the start is the start of the
parent end to the end of the parent
bottom top is to the bottom of the data
input
and i'm going to leave off the bottom
constraint now because it might just
fall off the edge of the screen without
any trouble all right we
give it an id let's call this thing
lview for list view
and i'm going to call it weather report
or weather
yeah weather reports i'm going to use
the the plural for
more than one all right so that gives us
a
idea of what's coming now let's just run
this and see what it looks like
all right you can see that the it says
gradle is finished
my rest api changes to the new app
and it says weather api app so you can
see that i have three different buttons
i have a city name so i can type in
something here and then when we're done
we're going to be able to generate the
city's
weather report down in the list view
below so that's the first step
now this is kind of a tedious process so
i'm going to provide you with the
xml file which is this code right here
so
you don't have to retype everything like
i did and that will
adjust any for errors if you've got any
so under the next video we're going to
start creating some
button listeners so that way when these
buttons are clicked they do something
so that's coming up soon hey welcome to
the third video of our application for
doing a weather report
as you can see in the previous video we
created a layout in this video we're
going to create some button listeners so
that each of these buttons
are now active
[Music]
so let's get started with creating some
code that makes these buttons
work so i don't need to look at the xml
file anymore so i'm going to just close
that
and let's get into the code here which
is main activity java
you can find that here in the folder
called java and then the first project
folder
and main activity so the first thing we
need to do is get the values of all the
buttons
and their id numbers so the first three
things that i'm going to capture
are the button names so let's put in the
button class
and then i'm going to assign a value for
each of these buttons so we can
program it so btn underscore city id
get weather by id and get weather by
name i think those are pretty close to
what i named them in the layout
they don't have to be exact but it
certainly helps if they are almost exact
the other two controls on the screen are
the lists view and the edit text so edit
text is et data input
and list view i'm going to call lv
weather report
all right so i've got those three uh
categories here and it just occurred to
me that these are all in the wrong
location
notice i typed them inside of where it
says on create so i'm going to
control x to cut them out and move them
up
so that they are now class member
variables they're called so these are
accessible
for all of the code that will appear in
the main activity
so that makes it much more easy to
program
all right so now when the oncreate
method is called
we're going to assign these things a
value so
let's go one by one all right so let's
get the first three buttons so btn
underscore city id equals and we're
going to find its id number so we use
the word find
view by id and r dot i
id gives us the resource value so that's
what r stands for
resource id number and then the name
that i assigned it in the layout
and the other two are just the same so
we're going to use find view by id
and try to match up the values in the in
the layout
and give them a value here in the
program
the same holds true for the edit text
and for the list view
so we use find view by id to capture the
actual
number that's assigned to these so this
is an integer that is
it is stored into the actual button
variable and the edit text variable and
the list view variable
so it's a good idea to comment your code
just in case there's somebody looking at
it that doesn't understand it as well as
you do
so i'll just say this is assigning
values to each control in the layout
this is pretty standard ideas so
hopefully you've seen this before but if
it's your first app
maybe not the best choice for your first
stat but i'll help you along the best we
can
all right let's move on to the next part
where we're going to actually now
create some listeners so the next
section is going to be click listeners
for each button
so that way when we click them we know
we have something going on
so the next section we are going to
create the set on click
listener for the button and you can see
there's type ahead code that makes us
much easier so we'll have a new on click
listener that comes out of this
this is a what they call an anonymous
function where it doesn't have a name it
just has the inline definition
and inside of this code we can create
events now if the button is clicked
so the best way to test a control is
sometimes just to put in a
toast let's test this one out to say you
clicked me
i'm going to check the rest of these the
same way so for each of these
buttons i'm going to do the same process
i'm going to
add the method called onclicklistener or
set unclick listener
and then inside of the parentheses we'll
create a new listener event
and for each of these i'm going to
create a toast message so that way it
tells me that
i've been clicked and you can see that
i'm going to now modify the
actual text so we can distinguish
between each of these items
so i'm going to run the app again so
i'll click this little circle arrow
it'll restart the app and then we'll
test out each button
so let's test this out if i click the
first button
nothing happened if i click the second
button it says you clicked b2 that seems
to be working and
third seems to be working so this is why
you test out your code as you run
something went wrong with button one
what was the matter with it
something didn't happen correctly let's
just double check everything
and make sure we got the name so the
button name
is called get weather by id and that
is also down here so that is the
incorrect name so let's try that again
btn
let's do by city id and let's save that
i think that might be better because
we had two click listeners for the same
button
and obviously the second one wins the
first one was ignored let's uh let's try
that again
all right so we're up and running let's
go and choose get by id
and what happens now so now we have a
you clicked me one
you clicked me two hopefully comes up
and three
got all of them now let's do one more
thing i'm going to put in the city name
here
and then we're going to echo out the
name of the city as we try each of these
buttons so let's go and grab the value
from the weather by name let's see this
would be a good one the third button
we're going to add in some new code so
instead of
you clicked me 3 i'm going to put in
this
you typed and then i'm going to put in
the value
that comes from the edit text so let's
do et
input data dot get text
and then i'm going to use a tostring
method so that should get
the text that was entered into the edit
text
and then re-displays it on the toast
let's see what that does
okay so we're up and running now let's
put in the word kansas city how about
and let's then if i could type correctly
and let's try the third one that says
get by name
and it says you typed kansas city so
that seems to be working
so we've got ourselves button listeners
we have the value of text that comes
from the data input
and now we're going to actually go and
do some coding that will get the values
from the weather report service
hi and welcome to the fourth video of
our series on using api services with
android studio
we're going to translate the text that's
over here on the left side
and put it into the app that's over here
on the right side
[Music]
so in order to get actually produce a
something that's sensible from the data
on the left side we're going to have to
get some tutorial information
on how to use a library called volley so
to help us through this process
of using volley i'm going to the actual
developer
documentation from google so
developers.android.com
training volley that's what we're
looking at so the section that we're in
right now is called
transmitting data over the network using
volley there's
actually something previous to this if
you're interested how to handle
general network traffic so this is kind
of the
overview of the old way or the
pre-volley
way that was done things and this this
will work if you want to go through this
process
however google is recommending that we
use a library called
volley and it's right in their official
documentation so let's go see what it
says about what we're going to do
so volley what is volley volley is an
http
library okay translate what that means
is
we can take a library extra software
install it into into our project it will
handle
http traffic or let's say
it will be able to handle text that
comes in this format this json text
and then it will translate it into
something that we can use in the app
so it is it's it they work they use the
word easier
and faster easier and faster than what
it's easier and faster than the previous
section called network operations
and it says volley is available on
github well we don't actually have to go
to github to get it
we can use it right in our dependency
manager so come down to this section
that says implementation and it says
we're going to copy
version 1.1.1 nice number there
now we're going to put that somewhere
let's go back into our android studio
so to put in any dependencies we go down
to the section called
gradle scripts so what is gradle gradle
is a dependency manager and we want the
second option
double click here so a dependency
manager
takes a look at the code that you see at
the bottom of the screen
you can see i just pasted in the new
volley library
everything that is in this list called
dependencies
is automatically downloaded from their
source which is probably github
and it copies all the files to your
project that you need
and then those libraries magically are
usable in your code
so there's a lot of work done behind the
scenes you don't have to download and
install
files the dependency manager does that
for you
so it's going to say go to this website
find
volley version 1.1.1 now there might be
newer versions out there but
google documentations are using this so
let's let's choose that
as soon as you add anything to the
dependencies list
you'll get a message at the top of the
screen that says gradle files have
changed since the last project sync
a project sync may be necessary well
maybe is kind of a
strange word it will be necessary so
let's go ahead and click the button that
says
sync now now at the bottom you will see
a message that says your status is
finished
so something was just installed on our
program
all right so everything looks uh green
there's no problems so let's move back
to our documentation
so it says now we've done this uh you
can also
okay we're not gonna have to do that
okay we have some lessons in here
how to create a simple request a request
queue
a standard request and a custom request
all right so looks like we'll start at
the simple and then we'll build up from
there so
the process that you're going to see in
the next few videos is we're going to
create things a simple way
and then refactor it to be a little bit
better for
more scalable programs so some of our
code is going to start to look like
spaghetti code and then we're going to
separate it into its
appropriate classes and when we're done
we'll have a pretty decent looking app
that is modular and that way all the
pieces are kind of
in their own place let's start with the
first one that says
send a simple request let's try that
so a simple request means we're going to
go and get a weather report
so here is some code that we're going to
work with now
we're going to modify most of this but
we will have a pretty good idea of how
this works by the time
the video is over so before we get to
that it says
you need to add the internet permission
to your app's manifest
so android permission internet let's go
check that out so i'm back into my
project
and the manifests are up here in the
folder called manifest let's go and open
that xml file
so we're ready to add the permission
into our manifest file so right up here
before the word application i'm going to
start typing
i'm going to use an open bracket so
like the less than sign and immediately
the type of heads
helps telling me there's things that you
can put here what are you looking for
and what i'm looking for is the first
one that says uses permission
and isn't that nice it provides me some
type of head code that says
what do you want to make this
application access
well internet is the key because we are
going to be
looking at data that's online so let's
close the tag
and we could use the tag closing as it's
here or i could
just put in a slash and that's a
self-closing tag so either one of those
is acceptable so now we will
automatically get permissions this
doesn't require the user to click
anything
so there's no special code to see if
they've approved or denied the
permissions so
internet permissions is pretty standard
so there's just one line of code
okay so now we've got ourselves the
permissions now we're going to come down
to the
request queue and let's see what all
this is going to do
so we need to have what they're going to
ask to fill in a text view we don't have
a text view we're just going to use a
toast
but it's almost the same i'm going to
copy all of this
right down to the last line so i'm
leaving out text view
and i'm going to copy and bring this
right into my project
and where am i going to put it well i'm
going to put it in the first button
so the button here
has got the first click listener and i'm
just going to paste
everything inside there alright so a
whole bunch of stuff just turned
redline we're going to have to add some
new libraries it looks like
so when we click the button the first
thing that happens
is we are going to initiate something
called
a request queue a request to what
a request to the service online and so
the queue means that you can't like have
simultaneous requests they have to get
in line they have to
take terms so the request queue is this
object that's going
to be like a a lineup so it says here if
you want to import the class we'll do
that
so we just imported it there should be
something new under the imports
so do we have a request queue yeah line
12 says we just
imported this from the volley library so
remember we have volley as one of our
dependencies
if we didn't put in the dependency down
here in gradle
then this exercise would have not worked
right now
so we've got ourselves the first line
fixed now the next item says we're going
to use an object called
volley and that also needs to be
imported so let's see if i can press alt
enter and it says we've got a new
request
now what's going on here it says the
context context says this
doesn't work so what's the matter with
it it says
your context is supposed to be
of the main activity context okay so
context is real confusing
if you want to see a previous video on
context look in the playlist here i've
created some android tutorials
on understanding context anyway the
context tells you where
is this thing in the program so i'm
going to type in the word main
activity which is this class file and
then dot
this so that is the context of where
this is being called from
it's being called from main activity all
right so what's the string
well it's not from google.com let's
delete that
and let's go get a string from somewhere
else so
i'm going to go back into my browser and
i want to get this string
from one of these api services
so let's go find out what that would be
up here so
i want a string to look like this here
the one that says query equals london
and so i want to get the id number of
the city so this is the one that's going
to work
so i'm going to copy this whole url
so let's do right-click and copy and
we're going to trim off the last part
that says london
but we'll use most of it so let's go
back into our code here and for it says
string url
we're going to keep it as london for now
just to make it simple
so this will only work for the city of
london
all right so now we've got ourselves a
request
and a url so the first thing it says
is we're going to get a string request
now there are different types of
requests that we can use
string request is the one that we will
probably not use
what we're going to ask for is called a
json object request or a json array
request because as you look at this data
this is clearly json formatted data
which is java
object notation and so we're going to
skip this string thing in just a minute
but for right now let's keep with the
code as they've given it to us so string
request
let's do alt enter and we'll import the
class
okay so we also have to do this other
alt
enter keep importing these things
okay got it all right so here's the part
that says text view
let's get that out of the way and the
response of the substring
so let's just take let's take we know
that the response is coming back
and it's going to provide the first 500
characters well i'm going to just delete
all that
and the comments so what i want to do is
just display the whole thing so i'm
going to put it into
a toast so i'm going to use toast again
and let's go to the text here and say
instead of the string i'm just going to
put in the word response so
what comes back from the response will
be texted out
in a toast all right so now we have an
error listener so let's go and
import these it looks like we have to do
more alt enter
import the class and instead of using
the text view i'm going to put in a
toast
and i'm going to say something like a
problem occurred or error
all right so then we get to the end
so this request object is all bundled up
from
line 49 to 60. and then
once we're done it doesn't actually
occur until we add it to this
queue so what's the queue and
where did where did we assign that so
the queue was assigned up here
a request queue and then we added
the request to the queue so that means
we could add more than one request and
it will
take them in sequential order and then
we're done we're going to have another
text so let's uh let's just
comment that out i don't want to see
that all i care to see
is what was given back from our london
query
okay let's cross our fingers and run the
app again
all right the app's up and running and
so it doesn't matter what we type in
here remember we're hard coding the word
london in here so let's choose get city
id
and look at there let's hide that
keyboard and try it again
here is our here's our response it says
title london let's look at that again
all of that is the same thing that came
through
from our code here so it says title
london location type city
let's run it again compare the two side
by side
you can see that they are the same thing
so this is formatted nicely and this is
just a straight old text
but the concept is there now we're going
to change some of the code here
and we're going to make this into a json
object so you can see
that there are two different types of
brackets here this is the
curly bracket this is a json object and
this is the square bracket which means
this is a json
array so what we want to do is get a
json
array object just because that's the
type of data
that's printed on the screen if we were
to look at a different one of these
requests such as one of these down
below here let's get london and let's
look at the data you can see that the
first
character in the json is a curly bracket
so this would be a json object that
we're trying to
to collect and then inside that json
object you can see that there is a new
array
and that array contains like six or
seven different days of weather
so two different types of json data that
we're looking at here either a json
object
or json array so let's go back to where
we were
which was this london query and we are
going to be looking for a json array
object so let's go back into the code
and modify a little bit
all right so i'm going to probably
delete all of this here
and uh let's comment it out first of all
so
put in a control forward slash to put a
comment from everybody
all right i'm going to type in a capital
j now look what we have for options
what i want are one of these two right
here so json object requests
that's if you were expecting to get a
json object in this case though we're
expecting a json array so i'm going to
choose
json array request i'm going to call it
request
and just like i had before i'm going to
use the same model
so you can see that the the text
here is a good pattern to follow so
we're going to have a new
and this time i'm going to have json
array request what are the things that
we're going to
fill in for the parameters so the first
parameter we need is
request.method.get so let's just type in
the request
dot method let's see capital m
and then get so that's the type of
request so in
in apis you can have gets posts deletes
puts and updates those those are all
things that are that are different types
so get and post are the obviously the
most
common ones if you've seen those in any
kind of programming before
okay so the next item is the url so the
url is the string that's above us so i'm
going to just retype url
and now the the next part is the
response
so i'm going to type in a new
and then the word response
and i'm looking for a response listener
so i'm going to type in response
listener
and what kind of item am i supposed to
put between these brackets
you can see before it was expecting a
string well i'm expecting now a json
array so let's type in json array all
right so you can see that we now have a
semicolon at the end
and i'm supposed to have more code to
help me out here so let's uh let's go
down to this
helpful hint that says implement methods
so listener is going to have a two
two items it's supposed to be a response
with a success
and also down here a error so let's see
if that'll
generate that for us i'm going to choose
implement methods
and sure enough there is a response so
let's click ok
all right so the first one was created
for us okay so it
generated the first results okay but i
think what we need
is another result which is on failure so
let's put in a comma right before the
end
and let's put in the word new response
and i want to do a response error
listener
there we go and the error listener needs
to have
its methods man i wish this would give
me some more type ahead automatically
but i'm going to go through the steps
one at a time
all right so i've got myself what looks
a lot like the previous code that we
coded but we've got an error
so let's uh hover and see what the
problem is
okay it says here in your json request
it says
i cannot resolve the constructor so
the constructor is
obviously missing a parameter that's
what a constructor does
it takes all the parameters and creates
an object so i've got
get url and the request listener so
something's different than
what it's expecting i'm not sure what it
is so let's go look at the documentation
and find out so i'm going to switch back
into my code
now i did a simple request and let's
let's take a look here at the what's
called the standard request
so a standard request instead of using a
string request like we did before
we're going to use a json object and
let's scroll down here it says
here's what you need to do your json
this one's called an
object request we did the array request
almost the same
and look at the look at the parameters
here so the first parameter is get
that's what we have url then there's
something called
null i actually don't remember what null
is for and then the rest of it
is what kind of a thing that you're
actually trying to request
so null is probably some kind of a
parameter that
maybe if i read the instructions more
closely it would tell me
but i don't see it in here but i'm i'm
going to take the word for it and put
the word null in
okay so let's go look here and
put in null and now it looks good
so the parameter was called json
requests no
i'd have to go look at more details to
know what that was
anyway the problem seems to have
disappeared
now we can go to the response and add
something now
so let's put in a toast so i put in a
toast
create a new one and what i'm interested
is is to know what comes back from the
response
so let's uh let's take the word response
then and instead of the text here let's
paste it it doesn't like that so the
response
is not a string it's a it's something
called a json array so we can just turn
it into a string with a two string
method and that's good
okay for the next item the error
listener let's put in a toast again
and let's put in a message that says
something wrong
all right so we've changed our data from
a string request to a json array request
and let's let's hopefully make this work
okay down at the bottom this turned red
i'm just going to cut that out and move
it up to the top here
so why doesn't it like string requests
our request
was called something else it's called
here
it's request so let's just copy this
and put it over top okay all ever is
gone let's see what happens
okay so the app's gonna run here and
before it gets started i'm gonna switch
over to the data that we
are expecting this this screen here and
uh
let's put in get city id there it is
so that was the same text that we have
listed here and you can see if you look
carefully it starts with a little
square bracket so we've got ourselves
the get city id
so we can do better than just getting
the entire json array
i mean the string did that the advantage
of using json data is that you can split
it up into pieces
so what i want to do first is get the
entire array and then get one piece of
that array
so let's go with this so i want to get a
the first item in the array so this is a
json object
and we're going to call it city info
and it's going to be from the response
so the response is going to be the
get json object and you can see that
it's expecting an index so the first
item in the list
so the first item in the list is the as
obviously it's an array of one item
so item zero is the first item now we
got an error it says
uh you have an exception that needs to
be handled because you're not guaranteed
to
actually get valid data so let's
surround it with a try catch
okay so we're going to try and do this
and if something goes wrong we'll print
the
error all right so now when we're done
we should be able to get get the actual
json object well i'm not interested in
the json object let's look at it again
the information that i'm looking at is
this this is the key
that i'm looking in this is the target
so w-o-e-i-d so i got the object which
is
this item now i need the key value which
w-o-e-i-d so let's let's copy him and
we'll bring him to the four
so let's go to the next line
so we got the json object now i want a
string and i'm going to call this thing
the city
id and so we're going to do the
city info dot get string
and now i'm going to paste in the name
of the string
isn't that cool so if that string exists
this try catch will succeed and we will
have a new string called city id
so that's the target that we're looking
for on this function so we're going to
call it city id
equals and then i'm going to type in
city id
oops let's try that again
city id okay
so now i won't let me use city id
in two places all right so you're
getting to see all the errors that are
coding as they as they occur so it says
i can't figure out what city id is
that's because we declared city id
inside the try catch and as soon as we
left tri-catch
the scope of that variable is now gone
so what i have to do
is define city id further out
so let's go and put it right above the
try
and let's say by default it's an empty
string
and i don't need to redeclare it and
then down here it works
okay so we're going to have city ids
defined then it's redefined as whatever
comes from the value
and then we print it here all right
let's see if that works we've gone a
long ways
we're going to run this i'm going to
bring up the web page so we can see the
id that we're expecting and then finally
what happens here so i click here the
city id
is 44418 beautiful
all right does that work for all cities
let's go and check
so instead of london let's change the
url now so let's put in a new city so
i'm going to put in phoenix
and save it relaunch the app
and away we go let's uh let's come over
to here and instead of london
i'm going to type in phoenix
so the id number is now this one 247
1390. let's see if we get the same
results over here so i'm going to choose
get id
and there it is 247 1390. okay so it
seems to be getting the id number
correctly
now i would like to be able to put in
the city name here
and then get the id so that's the final
step that we're trying to get to
there's been a long video but i'm
showing you all the steps that go into
trying to figure out the the code and
the documentation
so the query let's just take off the
city name
and now in the url
we're going to add to it a new value
so let's go with plus and let's get the
value from the data input field
get text and then i'm going to change
that to a tostring method
so now we should see whatever value here
is attached to the query
one more run data that we're expecting
and then the app shows up here so now if
i type in the word
phoenix and let's get rid of the
keyboard
choose get city id we see 247
1390. let's try somebody else
let's try miami everyone wants to know
what the weather in miami is so let's
check that out there's this the
ideas245022 let's go and see what miami
brings up on our app
miami i assume that's florida and what
do we get
we got an id number they seem to be
working so test this out with various
cities
now the reason why we did this one first
is because we're going to then get the
weather
report by that city id and so that'll be
the next phase of our video here
so this is a great stopping point we've
got ourselves one
item from our list and that is an
important id number
hi welcome to another video in our
weather app
in this video we're going to do some
refactoring so in this
current state we have a lot of code
inside a button
it's kind of uh complex and we're going
to have to make more buttons
and so the code will get longer so we're
going to try to do some refactoring to
make this
actually a little bit more well designed
[Music]
so i'm going to go to the documentation
that we were looking at here so
this was google's page we skipped over a
section called
request queue we're going to go back to
that down here it says
use a singleton pattern so the singleton
pattern
is common to lots of things in not just
java but
all applications and a singleton is a
class that can only be instantiated
a single time one time so the name
singleton
and all singletons are pretty much coded
the same way if you haven't seen one
this is a great introduction to why
they're important
so first of all what do we care about
for singleton and why do we only need
one instance
let's go look at our code here and
figure out where this would be
so the line that's important to us in
this singleton lesson
is on line 50. so we're creating a cue
called a request queue and then at the
end of the
code here we are adding a new request
so if you were to click the button
multiple times
it would multiply put in requests and
each request as you can see takes a few
seconds
now we don't want to have multiple cues
running
in our program one queue is good we just
can only handle so much network traffic
and so the idea of a singleton says
we're going to make a single class that
will be
listening for button clicks anywhere in
our application and it'll handle them in
the order that they're given
so that's where we're going with this
refactoring
all right so we're going to take their
code that they've given us here and copy
and paste it
and then modify it a little bit to match
our program
there's a few things here that we don't
need but we will
delete them so let's go ahead and we're
going to click we're going to
create a class called my singleton but
before we do that i'm just going to copy
here
and it copies the entire gray box and
then we're going to make a new class
called my singleton so let's go back
into the project here
right click in the java area and we'll
call it
my singleton now we're going to rename
that later to something like
data service signal singleton or the
request single content
okay so we got ourselves the code i'm
going to overwrite it so i'm going to
delete that and paste
and we've got ourselves all of the code
here
so request queue is the important part
we're going to have to import some
things here so let's do
import the class let's see i'll try alt
enter
image loader now we're not going to use
the image loader so i'm going to
get rid of him context is important so
we'll do alt enter again
all right so the next section down here
is called image loader so i'm going to
just come down
to this line here where it's got image
loader
don't delete this curly let's just
delete the image loader part
and let's see a couple more lines will
be gone now we have
we have a constructor it looks like so
the constructor
is important because it sets up a uh
the ability for only one of these
classes to exist
so it'll take a parameter called context
and then the request queue is the
important part says
when you're going to create the the this
singleton it's going to create
one version of the request queue okay
then the next part is
the singleton classic setup
so all languages would probably use
singletons this way there's a
there's a variable called instance the
instance is
does this thing exist already has there
been a version of this program
or this module is it in the memory
and this is a check to see if the
instance is null
means it hasn't been instantiated yet
then we're going to
make a new instance and if it is
already existing then we will just
return the one that's already there
so this is the key part this is what a
singleton does
it only allows one instance of the class
to be
instantiated created
all right so now let's go look at the uh
the rest of it so
the get request queue is important it
says if the request you doesn't exist
then we're going to invent it or we're
going to make it come into a bean so
let's use volley again
do an import and then down here the
request
looks like that needs to be imported and
then image loader
we're going to take out so whatever the
image loader was for we don't care
now we've got ourselves an entire
singleton
and there's no errors okay so this is
this is the way to handle the cue
let's go back into here and so i'm going
to comment out the existing queue
and we're going to create a new one
let's go look at the documentation to
see how to do that
okay so we're back to this page here
that shows us how to do this code
and now it says here if you're going to
make a request queue
we can do it two ways we can get the
queue
or we can simply add the cue right now
so
let's uh let's just use this line this
one's simpler so i'm going to copy
and let's go back to our code so i don't
want to instantiate it up here
instead i'm going to come down here and
delete
the line that was there and let's uh
let's put in
instead of string requests what was the
name of the request it's called
right up here it's just called request
so request
all right so the problem here is what
kind of
a context are we supposed to send
so we need to put in the word main
activity
dot this so this is where
it's being run all right so we've got
ourselves
pretty much the same kind of code i'm
going to delete the original
not a lot of changes in main activity
but the singleton
gives us the ability to manage this
through
central locations so let's delete all
the stuff that we had before
clean it up a bit
and hopefully i haven't wrecked anything
i've just done some refactoring
to use the what the documentation is
recommending so let's run the app
so let's see i'll bring up the bring up
the weather miami and let's
make sure that this is still working so
we'll get the same code here if i type
in miami
miami and then the button
and look at there it worked by the way
what happens if you don't put in
something so if i put in a
a city that doesn't exist does it do
anything
and it says city id is blank so it just
gets nothing
all right so it doesn't crash but i
don't get any value either
so that was a refactoring lesson so we
did this singleton request and now
if we were to have multiple things
happening at the same time the singleton
will handle them
in sequential order hey welcome to part
five of our video
on weather api app so we're going to
turn
this code that you see here into a more
componentized or modularized type of a
refactoring so instead of having a
button that has a lot of code inside of
it we're going to have a button with a
little bit of code
and then an external class with some
helper code to go with it so
we're refactoring here to make our
design better
[Music]
okay so let's get started on this
refactoring part we're going to create a
separate class that will handle
all of the items that are currently
listed in the highlighted section
so what i want to do is make a class and
put it in
the java class area so i think a good
name for this service is weather data
service it's sort of a database access
object but it's really for online
so the first thing i want to do is
define the types of methods that this
class will provide
so the first one here is going to be
return a string
called city id so we are going to get
the city name and then go through the
api process
and return a string which will be the
city's id
so all the code that we did in the
previous videos will be
reproduced here or copied and pasted
here and then refactored
we've also got two other things that are
in the future so i'm going to put them
in now even though they're not quite
quite defined properly so the list that
we're going to get
for the weather report is going to be a
list of type
weather report models so a model is a
class that's going to contain things
like the city name the high temperature
the low temperature the forecast
description and other items that we'll
find in our data service
and so we're going to have two options
for this we can provide an
id for the city and then get the weather
report
and then i'm going to refactor that one
to have a
simpler method called get the city
forecast
using the name or by name and so it'll
translate a name
of a city directly into a forecast and
so that's what's ahead of us
now as you can see the last two methods
here don't have some things defined that
we need to define so
i'm going to simply comment these out
for now
and just leave that as things that we're
going to have to do in the future
so we're going to encounter some
problems but
we are going to get this one here called
city id
working so we're going to return a value
hopefully
with a string now the return part is
going to be tricky because
this is not going to work like i expect
but i'm going to show you the process of
learning so that way
you can figure out some of the required
work arounds that are ahead of us
so the first thing i'm going to do is an
attempt to copy and paste
all of the code that's inside of the
button click
and then we're going to reproduce it
inside
of the other class so let's see i've got
to get this highlighted correctly
i'm going to cut this out
and then we're going to replace it in
the weather
service so let's go ahead and paste
everything here
as soon as i paste it says wow you've
got a lot of things that you're working
on for dependencies
let's click ok and import all those
classes
let's start at the very first line so
we've got this
string url and then it depends on a
text item and so we don't have a
reference to the
the edit text item so we're gonna first
of all
delete this and change it to a parameter
so we're gonna call this thing city name
and so you can see that city name is
being passed in
as a parameter so that's good so let's
just uh see what we would do
if we were to use this right now so the
goal here is to get the
city id number and it's going to come
from our
new class called weather data service
dot
get city id and then we're going to
provide the string which is
from our edit text data input
get text to string so
this here has got some issues we've got
a problem here that says
get city id doesn't work so so really
rather than just talk about the class
itself
i need to make an instance of it so
let's copy
and paste that and we'll call it a lower
case thing and we're going to have a new
weather service weather data service
and then for here we put in the
lowercase and everything's good so
the instance is created and now we uh
can get to the methods so so far so
this makes this makes sense uh it's not
going to work yet
there's still problems ahead but this is
the goal that i would like to do is a
normal java class
so let's start with this first line here
we've got a string here that's encoded
right into our in into our method so i'm
going to make this an extraction so
let's see if we can refract refactor
extract into a constant so here's a
trick that you can do
and it puts this constant name in there
that's kind of a long name let's just
call it uh
query for city
id i like that and let's
press enter okay so now you can see the
new constant declaration is here so it's
a public static final string
and then it just copies that string up
there so it's just
replacing one string with another so the
constant is got capital letters by
by a convention and then if we have to
use that again we don't have to use a
second copy of the
actual string so it's a good idea to
have one source of truth
all right for now let's let's keep going
down so we're going to do a new request
we're going to do a response query and
then we come down to
a problem here so we've got an issue
this was the context of main activity
well we don't have main activity anymore
this is no longer
accessible so what we want to do is have
a
value of the con of the context here is
part of our
our class values so let's let's come up
here and put in something called
context and i'll make a lowercase
context let's import the class
now how am i going to assign that that's
going to come in the form of a
constructor so
let's make a generate a constructor here
so let's go to generate
constructor and you can see it says
you've got a member variable called
context
and let's make that a very a parameter
that we pass in
and then we'll assign it here so this
constructor is going to modify something
back in mainactivity
so what did we do in main activity we
created a weather data service
and you can see now it says you're
missing a parameter
well we can get that mainactivity.this
is the context so we're sending our
context of main activity
back to here all right so since we now
have
a member variable we'll just put in the
word context down here
all right so does this all work
let's see not quite we've got another
issue let's change this to context as
well
and finally the last one
all right so now we've got everything uh
fixed up here but we've got one error at
the end
what's what's it say here it says you've
created
a return type of string and you're
there's no return here so we want to
return
this the city id so this is where we're
going to have problems
if i type in city id
we are going to have issues and it's not
just the fact that it's out of scope
this literally will not work and we're
going to have to create what's called a
callback but we'll get to that we'll
demonstrate first that it doesn't work
so what's the matter here city id
where was it defined it was defined up
here inside
of this uh response so i would like to
change this as well so i'm going to
move this to a higher scope i'm going to
cut copy this and let's let's just put
it up here
as a member variable and then down in
here we're going to take out the string
definition
so now the scope says we have a city id
here
it's referenced here it's referenced
here and then hopefully returned here
so it's not going to return it but we
should be able to at least
get the same kind of a toast message
that we did before okay so back to here
notice how short then our code is so
our string is going to come back from
the data service and let's try toast to
see if it actually works
so i'm going to say
returned and i d of
and then we're going to have the city id
so hopefully we're going to get the
response from the weather data service
and then redisplay it here so there's
going to be two toasts
this toast here is the second one inside
here was the first so when we
first get the city id from the api it'll
toast it here or something wrong one of
those two will
happen and then finally we'll get here
now i believe that this is going to come
out as empty it won't work
and then we'll have to solve that
problem but let's test it
we're going to run here and let's go get
ourselves to
the data that we're expecting let's try
miami again
and run the app
okay so here we are let's type miami
and hide the keyboard so the first
toast will come from inside the
program so the city id equals that
and we got we got a quick message there
that said
returned a null did you see that i'm
going to show it again it says
no but then city id equals
a number so one of the toasts got the id
the other one does not let's go check it
out where was that
so the one that said returned an id of
null was here
so i'm going to put in here this
didn't return anything
why not that's kind of unfortunate
i told it to return something but it
didn't
however inside of the weather data
service
it actually showed me a city id so i'm
going to say
this worked but it didn't return
okay so the comments here show me that
this part works
and it didn't return it to the uh to the
main activity okay so how are we going
to solve this problem
so we have just uh introduced ourselves
to an
asynchronous issue what has what is
happening
is that the first toast
shows that there's a null value getting
returned it like
immediately skipped down to return id
and all of this process was kind of like
left in the dirt it was left in the dust
it skipped over it that's because we are
running
a background process uh the
volley library automatically
puts in a cue kind of a background
request
because it takes a little while for an
api to return
some data a couple of seconds that's all
it takes
but we're not going to wait around and
freeze up the app and make the user wait
we don't want to make things run on
what's called the
the ui thread which is the user
interface thread
so we put it this we put this process in
the background and we just kind of let
it
go and it takes its time because we know
it's
er slow the unfortunate result is that
the
city id doesn't get assigned anything
while this is in the in the process
so by the time we get to this line you
know
we've skipped over and we never came
back to wait for it
so the the solution here one of the
solutions that we can use
it's called the callback so let's let's
see if we can get a callback to work
correctly
call back is a way to notify the program
that
when this process is finished run
another method
so you can take your time but when
you're finished i will be here waiting
so that's what a callback is now in most
languages
there's some things that have gone
beyond callbacks
so callbacks get messy they start to get
nested brackets until you get two three
four levels deep
and you lose track of your parentheses
and so that's called callback hell if
you get too deep and so unfortunately
developing apps in android and java with
callbacks is
still working in that method other
languages such as javascript and c-sharp
and things like that
have async and a weight
for a newer way to manage things so
there's probably ways to do async and
await with
libraries in java but i'm just going to
show you the callback method
because it's built right into the
language so let's go look in some
google queries about how to do this so
i'm looking for the phrase android
callback
with volley now you'd expect the first
thing to come up would be
a documentation from google's developer
tutorials and i scroll through here and
i
i'm not seeing it so there is something
in here but this is not about
uh volley i looked at that one so i'm
going to just go with my
stack overflow friends here and see what
this does
now i already checked in here and i know
that there is a good explanation
for how we're trying to handle this so
i'm coming down to
the first answer here it says there are
three answers for this guy's problem
and this is this is a good code to
follow so it works uh i
tested it out so here is here's the
guy's issue he is using
a json object request very similar to
ours
we're using a json array request but the
principle applies
and what he did then is he first of all
defined
a volley response listener
so this here is some code that we're
just going to
copy and we're going to paste it right
into
our example and then make a little tweak
here that
like he did okay so the
first thing that i'm going to do up here
is before my
actual event i'm going to put in this
interface
a volley response listener
so you can see that the the goal here
for this response listener is to have
two different methods one's called on
error and it's going to have a string
message
and the other one is an object response
so what kind of response
are we expecting out of this thing so
out of our
our response here we are pretty much
getting the city id
the city id in this case is a string so
for my
return type here i'm going to change
this to a string and i'm going to call
it
actually city id just so i know
what i'm expecting to come back so
the volley response listener is specific
to this method for right now
so now i'm going to insert this response
listener
into my parameters here so let's look at
the
the calling definition here so i'm
expecting one parameter but i'm going to
add a second one
all right so this one here i'm going to
put in as a volley response listener so
remember volley is the library we're
working with
and then when we get back to main
activity
we can implement these two methods
called on error and on response
now before we get to the response we
need to actually make it happen so
come down into my code to where the
comment said
this worked this is where we know that
the city id
has a valid number in it so we are going
to use the
volley response listener and we have
two choices we have on response and
on error see that's the two first two
items here
those are the exact same names as were
defined up in this interface
so we're going to choose on response and
then
provide the city id as the value that's
coming back to the
main main activity now
let's uh also put in the error so we're
going to do the same
process here we're going to put in a
volley response listener dot
and this time on error and we'll say
something wrong that's what's going to
come back instead of a city id
it's going to return something wrong
okay so this
is the key to link the correct
values to our main activity
as a matter of fact since this was
useless this return
i'm going to comment it out and i'm
going to change the return type from
string
to void it doesn't seem to work doesn't
work actually so we don't even need it
but this response listener is going to
help us
so back to main activity we got to add a
new item
see we got a red line it says your
weather data service get id
has now two parameters the second
parameter
is a new we're going to call it new
volley
response listener
look at there so you can see it's giving
some type of head help i'm going to
press enter
and beautiful it now implements
two different methods for us on error
and on response so we are going to
take the toast message cut that out
and put it inside of our response
and instead see city id is coming out
here city id
and then we're going to put another
message in here and just say
text is that something's wrong
something wrong okay i put a comma
and what do we got we got an error still
all right so the error says you have
expected the weather data service to
return a string oh okay
i'm going to delete that part we didn't
actually
uh implement that anymore okay so now
careful let's make sure we got
everything right here now the
get city id method is going to
have this link called the response
listener which gives us
an error message or response message and
one of those two
should come out so that is a
callback let's see if a callback
actually works
so i want to remove the toast
from inside of the data service
so nothing more from there that's
just getting the data and the toasts now
that are exist
are here and here okay let's run this
okay let's switch back into the weather
id
and get the app up and running
and let's see if we can get a valid id
to text out in front of us so let's go
to miami again
and remove the keyboard and choose get
city id
okay it says it returned a value it
seems to be working
let's try london and let's minimize the
keyboard
and choose get the id looks like we got
four four four one eight
so the process of doing a callback is
a little complex it's a little awkward
but it works
so we have now successfully created a
weather data service and it has the
method called
get city id and we found out that we if
we actually want to get that value
we can't just return it as a string we
have to wait for it so we use a callback
method
all right one final refactoring
is this here is going to be used in the
other buttons so there's no sense in
creating
a new one each time i click a button so
i'm going to cut this
and move it up and so it now sits
at the class level and now what's the
problem here it says
it must be declared as final let's let's
just put as final there
and so now it should be working
okay so the next video we're going to do
is we're going to
take this nice pattern that we've
developed here
and apply it to the other two buttons
and so that's just ahead
hi welcome back to another video in our
weather app we're using an api service
as you can see on the left side
and we're trying to get the api to
display a weather
report over on the right side so we're
going to create this button here called
give me a weather report by id that'll
be coming right up
[Music]
so in the previous videos we were able
to get just the id of the
london uh city as four four four one
eight
now we want to take this four four four
one eight
and put it into our input field and then
choose this button called get weather by
id
and that will produce a weather report
and then in a future video we're going
to take the word london
and then go for get weather by name
but in the intermediate we're going to
just be happy if we can get it by the id
number so that's what's coming next all
right so let's go
and take a look at the code and see
where we're going to go with that
so this here right now is the button
click
listener and all it does is tell me a
toast that says
you clicked me too so we want to get rid
of that and change it to some
real code now we're going to use this
weather service id
so let's copy and paste all of this
code here and hopefully just not have to
do a whole lot of changes to it so i'm
going to copy him
and paste him down here so we obviously
don't want to do
get city id we want to get
weather by id i think that is the method
that's coming up so let's double check
here
we commented it out and let's see this
was called get
forecast by id i'm sorry let's comment
this back
in and i'm going
to use get forecast by id
as my next item
all right and then there's a bunch of
junk that's not working yet
because this obviously has not been
coded let's come back and fix these
errors but
first of all we have to make sure that
our weather service
is working so what is the first error
it says i promised it that we would be
using a list
of weather report model well that's
that's true but we don't have one of
these called the weather report model
yet
so let's uh cut this out and
put it into here and call this report
and we're going to make it a new list
and let's see we can't use list it's
going to be array lists
there and we have to import array lists
okay now here's the issue with weather
report model
the weather report model is supposed to
be a class that saves a whole bunch of
data fields
and we haven't defined it yet so let's
create it
and it's going to be in this package
right here
and click ok there it is so we have a
weather report model
now what kind of properties does it need
well to answer that question
we have to go look at the data that's
been provided to us
so i'm going to go back to my api
and let's back up a few until we get
down to
one of these so we're going to do a re
forecast
so the forecast is going to look like
this it's going to have
all these properties in it so i could
probably just
copy one of these and start using my
weather model
based on the names here so let's
just copy that and let's paste it here
and i'm going to use that as a starting
point
so using the list of properties that i
got from the api
i am going to create all the properties
that will go
into this object called the weather
report model so
each one of them has its own data
property so you can see that the int
for id matches the type that's listed in
the strings above so it's an int
now most of these are strings so the
weather state name the weather state
abbreviation and the wind direction
compass
the created date all of these are
strings now some of these are decimals
so i'm going to use the word float as
the property for the number
and so we got floats for the max
temperature the temp the min temperature
the wind speed the wind direction
the air pressure doesn't have a decimal
point so it looks like that's an integer
humidity also is an integer visibility
we go back to float and predictability
looks like an integer so i'm making
estimations on which of these properties
apply but things with a decimal point
get floats and things that don't have
decimal points
are ins all right so we've got all these
properties now created
i can now just delete all of this helper
code that i had put in earlier
now what should we do with the rest of
this we've got the properties
we need some extra helpers so let's make
a constructor first of all so let's go
to
generate a constructor and let's select
all of the properties and click ok
and there's a lot of properties but
fortunately they're all defined for us
that saves a lot of typing
we need getters and setters for all
these guys so let's do a generate
and do getters and setters
and let's select everybody
okay now there's one other thing that
we're going to use later
it's the two string method so let's uh
let's define one of these maybe at the
let's see probably should go right here
let's define the tostring method
we can define that using generate as
well
and let's see tostring now i'm going to
click ok and select all of these it's
going to create
one really long string we're probably
going to come back and eliminate some of
these later because
this is a lot of information but for
right now that's a good valid tostring
method
okay so that defines a weather report
model so how are we going to make that
work
let's see we've got ourselves a list
problem
and we need to make this thing void i'm
getting rid of all these errors
so we have now defined ourselves the
weather report model and we know that
it's going to be
a list of we're going to call it report
so now the next goal is to untangle this
rest service data and we want to be able
to assign
each one of these properties into one of
the values of our weather report model
so let's first of all figure out what
kind of request we're going to ask for
this very first line here has a curly
bracket
so that indicates that this is a json
object the first property of a json
object is called
consolidated weather that's the property
and this happens to be
a list or an array we'll call it so
we'll collapse this and we can see that
each
item each item in our list has 15
properties and that's the end of the
list so how many items are there it
looks like one two
three four five six so there's a six day
forecast
you notice that so that the first day
shows today's current date which is may
25th
and then let's open the second item in
the list and you can see that that date
is may 26th
and i bet you 27th is coming up next
let's check
and sure enough so this is a forecast
for the next
six days for the city of london
now we're going to only be interested
in this property called consolidated
weather
we are expecting an array so this is
two requests that we're going to have to
get we're going to have to get the
object
the first object and then the property
of that object is an array
so let's see how this will go all right
so now let's
let's attack the problem here so we know
that we're expecting to get a
an object and then we're going to get
an array all right so let's pencil out
what we're going to do
because we need a road map this is
getting a little complex
so the first thing we need to do is get
the json object from the request
and then we know that the item in that
json object
is called the consolidated weather
which is an array and then each item in
that array
is an object that is going to give us
all the properties of a weather report
so it will become a new object called
weather report model
so that's where we're going so first of
all let's get the json
object and then we can start from there
so let's uh let's take a look at what we
did up here
so we have a request that looks like
like this here so i'm going to start
with a json
array request and modify it so let's
just copy the first line
and since we are looking for an object
i'm going to modify here so instead of
json array request it's supposed to be a
json
object request and let's modify this so
json object request
and the results are going to be a json
object not a json array okay we're going
to put
a close bracket there so what's the
problem it says
we're going to have an issue that says
you probably haven't implemented your
methods so let's choose that
and we want the on response so that
comes out
and it says we are expecting a response
of a json
object so compared to what we had before
this was a json array response
so we got one of each all right so
we got an issue with the url so the url
is undefined
and let's let's fix the url
so earlier we created a constant for the
url
up here we're going to make a new
constant so let's copy and paste this
one
and let's call this thing query
for city weather
by id and then we're going to delete
this
and replace it with whatever comes from
the documentation
so the the uh the url that we're looking
for it looks like this up here so
i'm going to copy and paste from the
address bar
so that's going to come into our new
constant
now the value here is the city's id so
44418 as i recall was from london
so i'm going to just take that out and
one of the slashes
so the url now needs to have a
definition so let's type in a string
here and call it url
and that's going to be the query for
city by weather id
and then we're going to have a plus and
we need to define it as
an addition to this value here the city
id
so concatenate those two together and
you get yourself a url
okay what do we got going here this
it's is to have no parentheses there
okay so this is looking like pretty good
we got ourselves uh the jason response
all right so we've got ourselves the uh
response now
up above here you notice we had this
error listener thing
and we haven't implemented that down
here so let's add that
we're going to put in a comma and put in
a new uh what's it called response
error listener and that's the first
suggestion so i'll just press
enter and we still have something left
over here
we need to close off this parentheses
and then a semicolon okay so all these
callbacks really are difficult to keep
track of that's why people are trying to
get away from so many
nested events like this but we've got
ourselves a
looks like an event here that might be
successful
we're going to at least get the
consolidated weather now
from the uh the property in here so
let's uh let's check this out we can
probably get it so
let's make a toast for right now just to
test it out
and we are going to do the response
dot to string and i'm going to ignore
the error part
and let's see what happens this isn't
complete but we can at least test
it come back into our main activity uh
what did we do wrong here okay yeah
so this was i'm going to just uh
delete that and try again so i'm going
to try a weather data service dot
get forecast by id
and we're going to just put in the
string 44418
because we know that is london
okay so that's simpler to test than what
i was trying to do earlier
let's see if it works i'm going to run
the app
all right so the app starts starting to
start up i'm going to come back into
here
so what we're expecting is we're going
to get a long list of
items and let's see what happens so come
on app we're ready to go
and i don't have to put anything in here
i've got 44418 as my default id
and nothing
nothing nothing at all okay so i forgot
something obviously
let's go check it out and i think i know
what it is so
in the data weather service i created a
request
now what's supposed to happen to that
request after it was made does it
automatically run
no it doesn't so just just like up here
i have this
get instance and add the request to the
queue i need to do that
as well down at the bottom here so i'm
going to expect that to be the last
thing i do
and rerun the app okay so you're getting
to see how
troubleshooting happens you're probably
going to commit the same errors that i'm
making
so it's good to see the solutions as
well as just
a good code okay we running yet here we
go let's check the weather by
id and anything whoa
look at that we had a toast of a quite
a lot of text so that to me looks like
consolidated weather it's showing
all of the items that are in there so
that's
it's producing the data we expect but
we're still not there
so i think maybe in the next video i'm
going to show you how to
make a single request show
only today's date because i really don't
want to show the entire forecast
for the week that's a little
overwhelming so we'll do that next
hey welcome back to our weather app
we're using api services from a weather
service and we're making an
android application so if you're just
joining us go back and check out some of
the previous videos
in this video we're going to actually
convert from
this horrible looking toast as you can
see coming up here
it's got a lot of text so this huge
thing in this text
is going to be changed into a list that
shows up
in our list view so that's where we're
going
[Music]
all right so let's uh let's see if we
can tame this thing so we're trying to
get the weather by
id and we've got this long list of data
we're going to modify our request here
so
we're into this weather data service
class
and up until now we've been able to get
the uh the string here for
the response so this response here gave
us the entire json
object now i'm interested in just the
first item which
is the the class called the consolidated
weather
so what i'm going to do is just pick out
one of those things from the object
and it's we know it's a list of json
things
json object things so i'm going to
define a list of json object
and i'm going to call it exactly the
property that was in the api it's called
consolidated weather list
now to get that i'm going to have to go
to the response and i want to
get a what get a json something
sure enough there is one that we can
pick from called the json array
and the name of that is called
consolidated weather
so hopefully that works now the
hopefully part is where the computer
says no you're not going to just hope
for it
you have to surround this with a try
catch
because if it doesn't work i'm going to
produce an error
all right so now what do we got okay so
it didn't convert well here so the
problem is that it says
you are requiring a list and i found a
json
array well maybe we can do this we can
just
change this to a json array type so
let's go json
array is that in there json array
okay good so now i've got the right data
types i've got json array coming here
and the type that we're getting is a
json array
beautiful now i only care about uh each
item
individually so we're going to go loop
through this
and pull it out but before we do the
loop let's just pull out the first item
all right so what i'd like to do is
create a new
instance of the weather report model
remember that model that has all the
properties
and so i'm going to just say hey make me
a new one now i've got an error that
says
you can't make me a new one unless you
provide me with all of these properties
oh my goodness that's a long constructor
well it could be done
and uh it would be one long line so
i'm going to cheat i'm going to make
another constructor that has no
parameters so let's go back to the
weather report model
and i'm going to generate another
constructor so slip it in right here
below the first constructor generate a
constructor and this time i'm going to
not select anything
so let's see just select the first item
and there it is
this isn't a null constructor or an
empty constructor let's see if that will
work now
so now it's happy it says you can create
basically an empty weather report model
and then
one by one i'm going to fill those items
in so
i need to know the list of all of those
items so
uh wow this is a lot
so i might also just copy the list here
and i'm going to dump it in right in
this
section even though it's going to cause
some errors it's going to say hey i have
no idea what those properties are all
right so now i need an object that i can
pull all these properties off of so i
have so far been able to
get the json object response and then i
was able to get the consolidated weather
list
so i know that the first item in the
consolidated weather list is
a is a json object so
let's do that let's go json object
and we'll call this thing first day
from api and he is going to be the
consolidated weather list and we're
going to get
item zero
okay did it work so i know that i'm
supposed to get the first item out of
the list and it's going to be a json
object
but it isn't guaranteed to be a json
object so it says
do you want to cast this if i put in the
cast it says i'm going to convert this
into a json object
i think that'll work because in my in my
service
the first item let's take a check again
this is definitely the first item in the
list is a json object
so the cast should have no problem at
all
all right so now how are we going to get
all of these properties so i'm trying to
get first a to get a bunch of properties
so let's do
first day dot set and the first property
is that i'm going to set is the id now
we're going to get the id
what's going to come from the first day
from the api
dot get and i'm going to choose the get
item and its value is
id okay this is going to take a while so
just watch me type
all right so this next process is quite
tedious we have to go
and get all of the properties from the
first day from
api object and we're going to assign
those
to one of the properties in our model
which is called
first day that's the instance so you can
see i'm going to say
we're going to set the id and we're
going to get it from the
integer called id in our api
and then they're going to set the
weather state name which is also from
weather state name so we're going to get
these as mostly strings so it's get
string get string get string get string
however when we get down to the set min
temperature
we are going to encounter a float
and it doesn't have an option apparently
to get a float
so you could use probably get double or
get long either one of those
and it will correctly parse the value
which is a decimal number
and then we're going to assign it to our
property which is a float so
java does allow you to cast a double
or a long into a float
now when we're all done here we're going
to have all the properties with
the correct spelling so make sure that
they're all spelled exactly right
if they're one of them spelled wrong
it'll crash and we'll find the error but
it's better not to have that error of
course now since i've got all of these
things typed in now and hopefully you do
too
i'm going to then delete all of these
different properties that came from the
class
and when we're done we're going to have
first day as the proper
thing that's going to be returned so to
return it that's the catch
we need to come up with another uh
return type so
let's go and look at the volley response
listener i'm going to copy that
and i'm going to now use it in the next
item so i'm going to create another
interface
and so the response listener now for the
forecast so we're going to call this
thing maybe a
forecast forecast
by id response
and that is what's going to come down as
my
reti time to return so instead of
returning a string i'm expecting it to
return
a single value called a weather report
model
and let's just put him in there as the
return type that we're going to
hopefully
play with at the end let's see we have
to
tell it that we're going to expect this
so we're going to put in here the
forecast response let's see
for cast by id response
and let's see forecast by id
response very good
and now here we can do forecast by id
response dot
on response we're going to send back our
first day
man that was a lot of work to get to
there but this will hopefully return it
to our main activity
okay so the goal here is to uh send this
uh
first day response back uh let's check a
few of things up here so here is a toast
that responds it sends the entire object
so i'm going to
just comment that out we don't need him
anymore that was for testing
let's go to the main activity and we
need to now
put in the response listener so that's a
new
forecast
there it is response
so let's uh check to see if we on the
response here i want to do a toast here
and i want to bring back the what
was the object there it's called weather
report model
let's see weather report model and we're
going to do a two string
so for lucky we're going to get a
weather report
and if we're not so lucky we'll put an
error in so let's put in a toast here
and we'll say something wrong here and
we'll have to figure out what that is
in the error logs let's let's run it and
see what happens so i started up here
and run and let's try get weather by id
and looks like i get nothing
so something didn't go well so i'm going
to come back
into the code here i'm going to switch
to logcat let's see where the log header
there it is
and we've got an issue
line number 89 and 83 and here is a
message
no value for consol consolidated
so i spelled this wrong let's let's fix
that let's see click on
line 89 there it is line 89
which is this here so consolidated
weather i
obviously spelled wrong let's uh let's
copy
consolidated weather from the code right
there
and over over write my spelling error
okay let's try again okay rerun and try
it again
okay so all of this here it is get
weather by id
and we got a toast that shows all of the
properties of that weather
so that's a lot of stuff but it appears
to be working correctly
now there's one more thing i'm going to
change here before we're done and this
city id
city id and we hard coded a city id and
where was that at
so right here we're going to do the city
id
is not from four four four one eight i'm
going to get it from the
edit text data input and get the text
and change it to a string so now we
should be able to get weather for
anybody and anyone that the service
knows about
so let's check it out i'm going to try
putting in
london and i'm going to try to put in
some other names let's see
44418 get the weather by the id
and sure enough there it is now i wanted
to know what the uh
let's try some other city let's go with
phoenix again
and get the id number oh man i
don't remember how to copy that so let's
uh let's come back
into our api and see if we can get an id
number
so let's see london
let's change that to phoenix so we can
get an id number there it is
so i'm going to copy this 247 1390
and put it right into my
id there see can i paste it no i can't
let's try it 2 4 7 1
and nine zero i got that right and what
do we have
there it is i've got ourselves a number
that seems to be valid if i put in an
invalid number i'm gonna add a nine
what do we get and
anything anything at all
appears that it doesn't work so it's
causing an error anyway
if i put in a correct number i've got
myself a weather report
okay we're getting further along we're
going to now create a list of stuff here
and we'll show not just the first day
but all of the days of the weather
but this video is already long enough so
we'll save that for the next
next up is to create a list of the
forecasts
hey welcome back to another part for our
weather api app
in the last video we were able to create
a service that would give us the weather
id
for the first day of the report
so you can see that this list here is
for phoenix
and when i choose get weather by id i
get
one day so the first thing says light
clouds and that's what it says here
so what our goal is now is to take the
report here and show all of these
reports
and put them in a list
[Music]
okay so to create this list we're going
to have to modify the type of data that
is sent back from
our service so let's go look at the
service that was created
called the weather data service and this
thing is supposed to get an entire list
and right now it just does something
called first
day as you can see from our code here
this line here says just get me the
first day
so what i'd like to do now is to get the
entire loop
of the list of things so first date is
rather misleading i'm going to name this
as one day so let's do a refactor and
rename
and i'm going to call this thing one
day let's see if i can get it right one
day
let's call it one day weather all right
now instead of zero we're going to do
the loop
all right so i want to make a for loop
that's going to go from zero
to the length of the list and remember
the length of the list is consolidated
weatherlist dot length and then instead
of
getting just one item we're going to go
through all the lists
all right so let's do a couple of
changes here
i have a problem with spelling
consolidated weather so i'm going to
change this to the word consolidated
spelled correctly and then paste
over the others okay instead of item
zero it should be item i
so if you remember up at the top of my
class here i have a
list already it's called a mod it's
called report
and so let's let's change that maybe to
the word report
so i'm going to rename that and let's
call it weather report models
something plural so we know it's a list
now down at the end of the list we're
going to add one
all right so we're going to add one day
weather to the weather report models
now when we get to the callback instead
of responding with just one item we're
going to
talk to the entire list okay so that's
going to break something it's going to
say that your
your callback is not designed for a list
it was designed for a single item
so let's go and change our list up here
so
our callback is supposed to give us a
list
of weather report models all right so
it's going to do weather report models
and then the response here is going to
hopefully match with that
now let's go back into change in the
main activity let's fix it as well here
so this is supposed to
capture a an entire list of things
so let's change this to a list
of weather report models and
let's call this thing our same idea so
weather
report models and then we're going to
import the class
okay so now we have ourselves the list
here
instead of doing a toast we are going to
now include this
as part of our list view so we need a
layout adapter okay so now we have to
create two things first of all we have
to create an arrayadapter
and then assign that arraylap adapter to
the
list view so the arrayadapter is a class
that
contains a few properties first of all
the
context has to be set so we'll use
mainactivity.this for the context
and then we're going to dig into a
predefined arrayadapter
type so type in
android.r.layout.simplelist item1
so there are other different types of
simple list adapters we can pick but i
always go to this one it seems to work
fine
this is not something that i defined
it's something that was pre-defined
as something given to us in android the
last item in the list
is the actual list that's going to be
chosen
for the values and then we simply set
the adapter here into
so let's switch back into the
consolidated weather page where we can
see the
actual number come up and i'm going to
type in a number here so let's use
the exact same number that was given to
us so this is a 2
4 7 1 3 9 0 which is phoenix and choose
get weather by id
and there it is so this is a one item in
the list that's two items three
so it's not very easy to read but we do
have a list
let's fix it up so it's easier to read
i'm gonna go back and change the model
to string so let's go into the model
here so the weather report model
so let's just fix this up a little bit
let's uh get rid of some of these things
so like the
id we can get that out of the way
and let's see the weather state
i'm seriously just going to remove most
of this stuff here so we'll get the
weather state name
and then what else do we want let's
create
i don't really care let's get let's the
date is important
so let's put in the word um date
and a colon and let's see the
maximum temperature and let's just go
with those so
take everybody else out
and that shortens things up quite a bit
so instead of min i'm going to change it
to low
for max i'm going to change it to high
so i'm shortening things down
you can make this say pretty much
whatever style you want
it's just a string and let's uh let's
fix it
all right so let's see what that does uh
see if it's any better let's run it
and uh we'll get a shorter view for each
item in the list
okay so let's bring this back up again
so i can see this number
let's type in a number for 2 4 7 one
three nine
zero and get the weather
so i'm getting six different weather
reports but they're all showing
uh for the day five
thirty and so that doesn't seem quite
right let's go check it out 5
30. sure enough it says heavy clouds
and i don't understand why it's showing
just the last one
okay coming back into the code here i
realized i did something a little bit
odd
so this here was left over from the
previous
iteration of my program i created the
object and then i started the for loop
so i'm going to cut this out
and put it inside the for loop so we
recreate a new one
each time we go through the loop so we
create
a new object and then at the end we add
it so let's see if that helps at all
and the weather report model i'm going
to fix up a little bit here so
the so i'm going to change
we don't need to have this listed here
like
like that let's take that out and let's
see if that works any better
all right so it looks like this is
working better i put in the id number
for
phoenix and i get the report so
it could probably be formatted a little
bit better i need a space in here
so the two-string method isn't that
pretty but it could be improved upon
so what we're going to do next then is
instead of just showing the
number here which is impossible for me
to remember except for the one
i think was 444 118 which was london and
then beyond those two cities i don't
remember any of them
so for the last video or the last
section we're going to have to do
is create this button here called
weather by name
and so we'll put in the name of the city
such as london and that will generate
the
list of data that we have in front of us
here instead of trying to remember the
city's id number
so that's coming up next hey welcome
back to another video for our weather
api demo
in the previous videos we were able to
get a list of
data from the cities now instead of
typing in the city number i'm going to
actually be able to create this
view by looking at the city name
so in this section we're going to modify
the function here or the method
for get city name right now it just
tells me what i typed
so let's uh fix that so let's go back
into the code here and
we are going to add a new item into the
report so in a previous
video we created a promise down here i'm
going to uncomment that promise
and here's what we're going to do we're
going to change this to
void and we are going to get the city
forecast
if the person gives us the city name so
we were able to get the
values out of this thing if we were
using the
id number so that's not very convenient
so we're going to have to change this
to get the by the city name so here's
the strategy we're going to
call twice to the api to get our values
so the first is we are going to get the
city id given
the name we were able to do that earlier
then we're going to fetch the city
forecast
if we have the city id so we're
basically combining the two functions
that we've already created
all right so to start off here we're
going to call the function called
getcityid and we can provide it with the
city name
because that's given to us in the
parameter above here
now the response that is given from this
function
is a volley response listener
and so we'll create a new instance of
that and so we'll have two
different responses to handle one is on
error and the other is on
response so inside of response we can
now
claim that we have the city id so that's
what this function just got to us
now we're going to turn around and call
a second function which is get
forecast by id this method also has a
response
it's called forecast by id response
so this callback is also going to happen
and then when we get to the on response
item we have a promise that we
can make that says we have the weather
report and we can send that back to the
main
activity so we're starting to see nested
callbacks here this is where people
start calling it callback hell
because we can lose track of the
parentheses
and brackets very easily it's confusing
all right so now we have this claim here
that we have the weather report
now we have to create another response
and a callback to make this work so
let's define one at the top here all
right so we're going to create the
interface that's going to define the
callback so i'm just going to use it a
name that matches closely to this
function call it getcityforecast by
name callback and the same two different
types of
things are promised in here in the
interface we're going to have an on
error and a non-response
the response of course is the important
one we want to respond with a list of
weather report models
now that we have the callback defined we
can go add it to our function so we're
going to say that
we're expecting to see a callback called
getcityforecastbynamecallback
once that's defined we can come down
into our method on the response
from the previous callback and call this
one so we're going to do get
callback and we're going to say on
response
and we are going to then reply with this
thing called weather report models
okay that should reply correctly so now
let's go back into our main activity
and we can probably duplicate a lot of
the things that we did
from the previous guys so let's just
copy and paste
and we will modify so we got ourselves
here
instead of get by id we're going to say
get city by name
and we're expecting a different
reply
and so we've got ourselves here the list
and i think the weather report models
should come back
as we expect them to wow that was
a lot of code but let's see if it works
okay we're up and running so let's put
in a city
and let's hide the keyboard and choose
get by name
so hopefully london will now populate a
list of items
and we're getting nothing so oh
it did come up so it just took a little
while so why was it so slow
well it's slow because we're calling the
api twice
let's see if it's just as slow if we
type in another city
and see what happens so that one came up
quite a bit faster
so they're getting light rain in kansas
city and let's see what's going on
in lima down there in south america
looks to me like it's running so we've
got ourselves get by id
or get the city ids you can see it shows
up and if i try to get the id
i have to actually put in the number
here so let's put in four four
four one eight let's see one more extra
four there
so we can show london
that seems to work and then finally
we're able to put in a number
or name here so let's try new york and
see what the weather is in new york and
there it is they have clouds
so we've got ourselves a finished app
this here
is quite complex it shows us how to use
the api service shows us how to use
callbacks
and it shows us how to work with a
singleton so several
different things that are now new to
your toolbox in your java programming
kit
so please uh leave your comments below
to see if there's uh
any criticisms or any suggestions which
you would have to make this look better
so i think the first thing that i would
do is instead of using a simple list
adapter i would create
more of a complex one in the api
instructions
they're strongly encouraging us to use
icons and so if you look back
at their page here you can see they've
got all these icons that
you should probably put into your app
and you can show them as pictures
instead of just text in your forecast so
there's lots of things that you can
improve but this is a good start so
thanks for watching
and if you like the channel go ahead and
subscribe and look at some of the other
items
there's not only android programming
here but there's c-sharp
there's php a lot of work with databases
and computer security
so a lot of things to learn here and if
you're interested in studying at grand
canyon university
look us up online and you can see some
of these activities are actually taught
in the classroom so we'll see you soon